GOING ON.
BUT AS AND WHEN YOU GET MORE
INFORMATION, PLEASE DO KEEP US
UPDATED.
>>> IT LOOKS LIKE NOVAK
DJOKOVIC'S NEXT BATTLE WILL NOT
BE ON THE TENNIS COURT.
THIS WAS HIM BEFORE HE WAS
DETAINED AND SENT TO A
QUARANTINE HOTEL.
HIS LEGAL TEAM IS TRYING TO KEEP
HIM FROM BEING DEPORTED FOR NOT
BEING VACCINATED AGAINST THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THE HEARING INTO THE MATTER HAS
BEEN PUSHED TO MONDAY.
THE NINE-TIME AUSTRALIAN OPEN
WINNER GOT AN EXEMPTION TO PLAY
IN THIS YEAR'S TOURNAMENT.
BUT WHEN HE ARRIVED, HIS VISA
WAS CANCELED.
THE PRIME MINISTER SAYS THAT
DJOKOVIC DIDN'T HAVE A VALID
EXEMPTION TO THE VACCINATION
REQUIREMENT, THAT ALL TRAVELERS
TO THE COUNTRY MUST HAVE.
WELL, DJOKOVIC WAITS FOR HIS
COURT HEARING ON MONDAY, HIS
PARENTS SAY HE'S BEING TREATED
LIKE A PRISONER.
PHIL BLACK EXPLAINS WHAT LED TO
THE SHOWDOWN.
>> Reporter: AS THE WORLD'S
NUMBER ONE MALE TENNIS PLAYER
NOVAK DJOKOVIC HAS HIT MORE THAN
HIS FAIR SHARE OF ACES.
BUT THE SERBIAN CHAMP'S COVID-19
VACCINATION STATUS HAS PUT HIS
HOPES OF A 2022 GRAND SLAM OUT
OF REACH.
>> MR. DJOKOVIC FAILED TO
PROVIDE APPROPRIATE EVIDENCE TO
MEET THE ENTRY REQUIREMENTS TO
AUSTRALIA AND VISA HAS BEEN
SUBSEQUENTLY CANCELED.
SO, IT'S A MATTER FOR HIM
WHETHER HE WISHES TO APPEAL
THAT.
BUT IF A VISA IS CANCELED,
SOMEBODY WILL HAVE TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: LOCAL AUTHORITIES
HAD ORIGINALLY GRANTED A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION TO DJOKOVIC TO COMPETE
IN THE AUSTRALIAN OPEN.
AND HE PROUDLY ANNOUNCED HE WAS
TRAVELING DOWN UNDER ON SOCIAL
MEDIA TUESDAY.
HIS POST INSPIRED OUTRAGE FROM
AUSTRALIAN CITIZENS WHO HAVE
FACED SOME OF THE MOST SEVERE
LOCKDOWN TRAVEL AND VACCINE
PROTOCOLS OF ANY COUNTRY SINCE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN.
AND IT'S CREATED AN OUTCRY OVER
WHAT SOME PERCEIVE TO BE SPECIAL
TREATMENT FOR THE SPORTS ICON.
AUSTRALIA SLAMMED ITS BORDERS
SHUT FOR NEARLY 20 MONTHS BEFORE
BEGINNING TO EASE THOSE
RESTRICTIONS IN NOVEMBER.
BUT ONLY AFTER ACHIEVING 80%
VACCINATION, AMONG THOSE 16 AND
OLDER, WITH SOME STATES STILL
REQUIRING MANDATORY QUARANTINE
UPON ARRIVAL.
VICTORIAN OFFICIALS INSIST HE
RECEIVED NO SPECIAL TREATMENT,
SAYING A HANDFUL OF MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS WERE GRANTED VIA AN
ANONYMOUS APPLICATION PROCESS,
REVIEWED BY TWO INDEPENDENT
PANELS.
THE TENNIS STAR TRAVELED TO
MELBOURNE WEDNESDAY ON A VISA
THAT DID NOT ALLOW VACCINE
EXEMPTIONS, RESULTING IN HIS
DETENTION IN A ROOM BY HIMSELF
AT THE AIRPORT FOR SEVERAL HOURS
WHILE BORDER AUTHORITIES
CONSIDERED HIS CASE.
DJOKOVIC, WHO ALREADY CONTRACTED
COVID-19 ONCE IN 2020, HAS MADE
NO SECRET OF HIS ANTIVACCINE
STANCE.
>> Translator: DURING A FACEBOOK
LIVE WITH FELLOW SERBIAN
ATHLETES IN APRIL OF 2020,
DJOKOVIC SAID PERSONALLY I AM
OPPOSED TO VACCINATION AND I
WOULDN'T WANT TO BE FORCED BY
SOMEONE TO TAKE A VACCINE IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO TRAVEL.
HIS FATHER IS OUTRAGED BY HIS
SON'S AIRPORT DETENTION, TELLING
RUSSIAN NEWS AGENCY THE WINNER
OF 20 GRAND SLAM TOURNAMENTS HAD
BEEN HELD CAPTIVE.
THE INCIDENT THREATENS TO CREATE
A DIPLOMATIC REALM WITH SERBIAN
OFFICIALS DEMANDING ANSWERS FROM
THE AUSTRALIAN GOVERNMENT.
THE AUSTRALIAN P.M. TWEETED A
FORCEFUL DEFENSE OF THE DECISION
TO CANCEL DJOKOVIC'S VISA,
MAKING CLEAR THAT NO ONE WILL
RECEIVE SPECIAL TREATMENT NO
MATTER HOW FAMOUS THEY ARE,
SAYING, RULES ARE RULES
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
BORDERS, NO ONE IS ABOVE THESE
RULES.
OUR STRONG BORDER POLICIES HAVE
BEEN CRITICAL TO AUSTRALIA
HAVING O